el Doctor Carlos Ortuño se sube a un
pequeño carro eléctrico para ir a
visitar a una de sus pacientes en las
afueras de la paz el programa llamado
médicos en tu casa hace parte de una
estrategia del gobierno para acercar los
médicos a los pacientes que viven lejos
del centro de la ciudad y para eso se
les propone el uso de estos pequeños
carritos eléctricos es un gran sistema
moderno ecológico y bueno también la
tenemos que acostumbrar a la a la
sociedad paceña que a quien no conozca
el auto y pues nos nos colabore también
no en la circulación el vehículo se
mueve a 56 kilómetros por hora y puede
recorrer 80 kilómetros antes de ser
cargado en un enchufe doméstico la
empresa que los produce cree que puede
transformar la Industria automovilística
del país la electromovilidad en todo el
mundo va a reinar muy pronto pero va a
ser diferentes
en Estados Unidos será tesla y ese tipo
de autos de alta velocidad de mayor
autonomía etcétera Pero creemos que
latinoamérica la mayoría de los autos
van a ser de menor autonomía y más
compactos por qué Porque nuestras calles
así lo demandan en los últimos años se
ha disparado la demanda por el litio
también llamado oro blanco indispensable
para la fabricación de baterías de
vehículos eléctricos y de celulares en
Bolivia chile y Argentina podrían estar
el 85% de sus reservas mundiales sin
embargo la extracción de litio ha sido
criticada por las grandes cantidades de
agua que requiere